i wanted to mention the real cool benefit of
rebound exercise nasa has done quite a bit
of research on rebounding and i'm going to
put some links down below but it's actually
quite fascinating that they're doing research
on rebounding because what they found is when
you're in space without gravity you start losing
your bone tissue and your muscle tissue so they're
trying to come up with ways to counter that but
rebounding exercise is jumping on a trampoline
now if you're going to do rebounding and you're
a little bit older i would always recommend
doing it with some type of support structure so
you can hold yourself because you don't want to
be jumping on this trampoline and jumping off and
you know falling or injuring yourself but there's
quite a few benefits to rebounding exercise it's
convenient it improves your mobility your posture
your balance your gait it improves the fear
of falling it can even reduce your risk of
osteoporosis but i think the biggest benefit
has to do with this right here stimulating the
lymphatic system so let me make this very
very simple what is the lymphatic system
you have the blood vessels throughout
the body the vascular system right
and they go from large vessels to smaller vessels
to eventually to tiny little blood vessels called
capillaries in the tissue now in that same
tissue next to the capillaries you have the
beginning of the lymphatic system some of the
plasma in the blood leaks out into the tissues
and it goes right into the lymphatic system so
the fluid in the lymphatic system called lymph
is made up of plasma and several other things
which i don't want to get into at this point
and then the lymph system travels through
the body and then eventually dumps back
into the vascular system the venous part
of the vascular system so it's this whole
continual loop so one function of your lymphatic
system is to act as a backup for your vascular
system so if there's too much blood for example
the lymph system can handle that overflow
but the thing you need to know about your
lymphatic system is it doesn't have a pump
like the vascular system does so it needs movement
or else there's no pump the lymph becomes stagnant
or congested the two big purposes of the lymphatic
system are number one to support the immune system
because you have all these lymph nodes and you
have all these t cells and b cells that help to
capture and consolidate pathogens that have
invaded the system and deal with them kill them
and just disregard them as well as to help recycle
old red blood cells and damage red blood cells and
recycle them that's what the spleen does the
spleen is a very large lymphatic node and the
other function of the lymphatic system that a
lot of people are unaware of is that it helps
to transport fat to the body so when you eat
dietary fat and it goes into your intestines
it goes directly into the lymphatic system not
into your blood vessels fat in water do not
mix so the body has to package this fat in a way
that can be transported easily through the system
so one way that it packages the fat is through
something called a kylo micron the word kylo means
juice and microns mean small particles
so a kylomicron is very simply
the grocery bag that carries the fat to the
various parts of the body for both energy and
as a precursor or material to build hormones
especially adrenal hormones to counter stress
all of the hormones in the gonads the
testosterone estrogen progesterone are made from
fat and cholesterol the cellular membranes
need fat the nervous system the brain
needs fat bile comes from cholesterol vitamin d
comes from cholesterol so in other words this fat
is very very important to supporting body tissue
as well as giving you energy and one very common
thing that i hear over and over and over when
people start doing rebounding exercise is their
energy goes straight up and vertical i think it
has a lot to do with the fat being more activated
in the lymphatic system so the biggest benefit of
rebounding exercise has to do with supporting the
immune system and to help the transportation of
fat through the chylomicrons now as a little side
note since we're on the topic of chylomicrons i
want to just help you understand this a little
bit better when you get a cholesterol test you
usually get your total cholesterol you get ldl
hdl right now let's take a look at this a little
bit deeper when someone talks about ldl or hdl
they're not talking about cholesterol they're
talking about the carrier bag okay the the
grocery bag that's carrying the fat through the
body and so we have different densities of these
bags different sizes and different densities so
when we're going from a kylo micron that's the
largest bag it's also called the ultra low density
lipoprotein and they're calling it ultra low
because it's basically filled with fat and very
little protein and if we look at the relationship
between this all the way down to hdl you can
see this is a lot smaller this is the most dense
this is the least dense okay so this has the
least amount of fat the most protein this has
the most amount of fat and the least amount of
protein so when we go this direction more dense
more protein less lipids why because these are
carrier bags that are going to be dumping off
fat into various parts of your body so we
go from a cola micron which is an ultra low
dense lipoprotein to a vldl that means very
low density lipoprotein and then there's a
little extra step right here called intermediate
density lipoprotein and eventually we get to the
low density lipoprotein and most people think this
is the bad one but there's actually two types of
ldl there's one that's more pathogenic and one
that is non-pathogenic if you're interested
i put some links down below about that and
then we get the hdl which is a carrier bag
that takes the cholesterol from the body tissue
and brings it back into the liver these other
ones are going to the liver anyway sorry i got
sidetracked there for a minute the main thing
you need to know about rebounding is it's really
good for your lymphatic system especially if you
have lymphedema all right thanks for watching
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help